These censorship laws are springing up provincially and municipally.
Trudeau opened the door, so to speak,
and these lower level politicians walked right through.
For example, in Manitoba,
the socialist NDP government has moved Bill 8 to criminalize peaceful
pro life expression,
an even silent prayer on every taxpayer on public sidewalk
within a radius of 50 meters
around every abortion facility in the province.
And all of these cruel and dictatorial
censorship laws have the same goal
to silence Canadians
who are trying to defend the human rights of preborn children.
Lower level politician here.
This clip is laden with right wing dog whistles.
His portrayal of Bill 8 is inaccurate.
Bill 8 does not stop citizens from gathering or expressing their views.
Folks can still pray or protest.
It's just that now
they can pray or protest 150 meters away from a hospital
or a clinic or an abortion providers home.
As I've always said,
anti choice folks are more than welcome to come and pray and protest
here at the Manitoba legislature.
My Bill will increase safety and dignity for Manitobans
accessing a wide range of reproductive health,
including abortion.
I wouldn't have had to have initiated this legislation
if individuals weren't harassing and intimidating Manitobans
who are accessing abortion services.
It's as simple as that. Finally,
let me just say this. Uh,
leave it to a man to give credit to another man
for all the hard work that we
as women have done for decades.
In advocating for reproductive justice
and ensuring safe abortion access.
It's taken me almost seven years to get Bill 8 done.
But Bill 8 will receive Royal Ascent on Monday,
June 3rd, 2024, and will become law of the land here in Manitoba.
I'm super excited and proud of this work.
I dedicate Bill 8 to all of the women
and gender diverse folks who have fought for abortion
access and safety for the last 50+ years.
In particular, I dedicate Bill 8 to all of our US relatives
fighting the most draconian,
archaic, anti women,
anti trans, anti queer,
misogynistic, patriarchal laws seeking to,
to ban abortion. I will always stand with you
and I will always raise my voice to highlight what's going on
next door and also here in Manitoba.